okay so I'm gonna show you guys yeah I
can't ask her that assume the best okay
I will as soon as I find out but I
suspect that things will go on as normal
so just do what we've been doing that's
the theory yeah I don't think she is
well then you're on a virtual strike
what's that
yes what's that
okay well of all the stupid things I
can't send her the damn essays and we'll
see what happens
or in the future authoring stuff
eventually they're going to get graded
if they don't I will figure out what to
do about it
you're not gonna be left hanging with
this course okay so just do the door do
the work we'll figure out how you get
your damn credit I'm gonna do everything
I can so that you're not left hanging
because I don't think that's reasonable
you know the beef isn't with you guys so
so don't worry about it for now just
proceed as if everything will be worked
out okay okay okay
so I want to show you some images and
these are great far their images
fundamentally and I want you to take a
look at them because they're powerful
propaganda images and we want to see
what they represent so on
right you see Hitler there who's taking
over from Hindenburg I believe that's
right I can't remember he was the
president before Hitler came came aboard
and so you see that there's the transfer
of power from the wise old man to the to
the emergent hero that's the image on
the left right and so then on the right
well so what do you think about that
picture what does it represent what's
going on there what's that yeah we'll
just look at just look at the image
security it's the balance between Osiris
and Horus right it's different than that
that's close but you know it's a call to
heroism from the youth with the father
who's far-seeing and you know composed
serving as the protector and the model
so ya know that's your sort of ideal
Aryan youth yeah and it's an interesting
picture eh because it's it's actually a
picture that represents a child in a way
that you very seldom see children
represented you know because the child
is very serious and determined and you
know that's not an acceptable image of a
child generally speaking in a culture
that's optimistic and naive because the
kids are always like they're little
innocent things that have no power it's
like that's wrong yes definitely oh
definitely he's a great father
he's the all-seeing great father in the
background he's like The Wizard of Oz
fundamentally you know so yeah yeah so
he's partly ordered and that was a huge
part of Hitler and that's partly was
attractive because Germany was
absolutely in chaos so that made order
more and more attractive right so and
Hitler was a very orderly person so
and so what does that mean why would
that be the case that's right right so
that means they're above you you're
looking up at an ideal right and that's
because they're up in the dominance
hierarchy you're kneeling that's another
way of thinking about it yes yes they're
also lit from above
yes and it's far-seeing right they're
looking far ahead into the future that's
right that's good all right so then
there's the picture on the left so what
do you think about that oh well maybe I
can make it a little bit bigger
what you have is Hitler on the right of
the picture in the left and then a huge
number of people crowded around him and
they're all smiling and and joyful and
so that's a representation of Hitler as
the jovial father of the race right and
you see it said at a at a table and what
do people do at a table that's right and
they share it right and so that's a very
familial that's a very familial
enterprise and to share food with
someone is to bring them into your house
right and to be the distributor of food
is to be the benevolent father and then
on the right you see Hitler addressing a
large political crowd you know he's up
on a high platform with his men behind
him and then these these Eagles carrying
the swastika sort of arrayed behind him
so he's up again
so very good at theatrics the Nazis were
very good at using theatrics so then you
see them on the left there what do you
think about that picture yet stoic and
resolute right yeah exactly okay and
then you have the mental picture where
the Germans are basically marching with
what are really remade roman banners you
know and so what do you what do you what
does that image show
yes it's that's exactly right it shows
uniformity and solidarity
and the uniformity comes out because
everyone's the same right and that makes
them a powerful united force now you
might ask yourself well why would people
want that and so what's the answer to
that and power I mean you want to be
part of a like a powerful United force
or do you want to be like the weak
member of an if completely fragmented
society you know so now you might say
well I don't want to be too integrated
but you know one thing I would say is
don't overestimate the degree to which
you don't want to be too integrated
because you know modern people
especially in the West they like to
think of themselves as individuals it's
like I have a hypothesis about that I
think people in the West are actually
the most conforming people in the entire
world and that's why they can sort of
dance around on top of that like they're
free and the reason is everyone stops at
the red lights you know everyone obeys
everything virtually and so you can
dress weirdly and maybe you can have a
bizarre opinion and you can go off and
do something that's a little out of the
ordinary in some corner but 99% of the
time you're conformist right to the damn
bone and that's a good thing because if
you weren't the society wouldn't be so
stable and so predictable across you
know reasonable spans of time so but the
idea that the West is individualistic
it's like we might represent
individualism as a form of deity and
aspire to it and we might even worship
it when it occurs because we do with
celebrities and so forth but that's why
it's bowed by no means reasonable to
assume that the West is primarily
individualistic you know I mean I grew
up in western canada and in edmonton if
there's a light that's red like if you
know you're supposed to not walk people
will stand there on the street when it's
40 below and wait until the light
changes even if they can't see a car
anywhere near in any direction like it
was quite shocking to me when I first
moved to Montreal and people were
jaywalking you know I thought God
Himself was
to strike me down with lightning if I
did it you know now that the roads are
narrow and so that's part of it but but
Montreal is definitely a lot pushier or
as pedestrians than people in the West
and the other thing that's quite
interesting about the West traffic
patterns is that if you're standing on
the road looking like you might want to
cross even if it's jaywalking Villa will
stop and let you cross it's quite
annoying because you're just standing
there it's like you know five people
stop and then you have to walk across
the street just not to disappoint them
so you know the thing about conformity
is it is it it makes her a tremendous
amount of stability and believe me we
wouldn't be promoting nonconformity if
everyone was non-conforming we'd be
thinking hey it's time to get this whole
thing conforming quite quite tightly one
of the things I've been thinking about
Islam lately is that you know when when
you when you want to define a religion
we determine it's a religion a religion
of peace or of war and you think well it
might depend on the level of analysis
you know one of the things that Islam
did was take a society that was very
tribal and fractious and United across a
large portion of territory so you know
what it did that by expanding its
domains and incorporating other people
and also going to war so on the fringes
of the Islamic expansion there was all
sorts of bloodshed and misery but then
inside it there was this hierarchical
organization of people that were
basically only organized into little
bitty tribal groups before that so you
might say well that within the expanding
bubble of influence it was peaceful and
then on the fringes it was violent and
then you might say well what does that
mean over the long run is that warlike
or peaceful and I don't really know how
to answer that question you know because
it depends on which angle you're looking
at it from you know we certainly know
that as humanity aggregated itself into
larger and larger collectives there was
a lot of conflict that had to be had in
order for that to occur but the
consequence like you think about our our
lives at the moment the probability that
one of you will get killed by a homicide
is
you know it's vanishingly low and then
you might ask yourself well how much
bloodshed and conflict did that take you
know before everyone was hammered
together so damn tightly that well
here's another way of looking at it why
is it possible for women to have rights
in the West and I think the answer to
that is because they can go outside
without being raped so you know it the
whole culture is so damn peaceful now
that it's a woman can present herself
alone to strange men and not die as a
consequence of it it's like okay well
then you can start talking about rights
it's before that it's whatever you're
talking about it's not right mostly what
it is is protection you know you have to
be protected and there's lots of places
in the world where that's still exactly
the way it is you know I know that even
when I was traveling through Europe
years ago when the 80s you know I
traveled with a friend of mine a woman
and her boyfriend and when we went
through Italy for example she was blond
she was just harassed to death by the
Italian men I mean not in any Norton
anyway that was brutal I'm sure it does
I'm sure it does
so we took her over to Greece as well
and we went to this place called Patras
and Patras had this absolutely weird
celebration that was like the fourth
biggest celebration in the world I'd
never even heard of it and one of the
things they do there is everybody goes
on the street with these plastic bats
you know they're really light plastic
that's the kind of kid would use and
they were like this big round their
plastic was firm enough so that it was a
bat but soft enough so if you got
whacked with it in a semi playful way it
wasn't gonna hurt and then everybody
also sprayed each other with silly
string which I thought was an extremely
bizarre nut stuff wasn't that also like
there's a million people out in the
street and everybody's hitting each
other with bats and spraying each other
with silly string and this poor girl she
must been hit like ten thousand times
you know so and it wasn't malevolent it
was playful you know it had to be
because if whenever
one's hitting everybody else with bats
it bloody well better stay playful right
but the pro thing is is that she
couldn't move with anywhere near the
same freedom that I could move and
that's only a tiny tiny echo of what it
would have been like in many places five
hundred years ago or a thousand years
ago so again you know there's this basis
of absolute conformity that's a
prerequisite to as freedom especially
freedom for people who are vulnerable in
many ways so that's part of what's being
celebrated in that image and you know if
people are in the state of chaos that's
one thing that really attracts them
they're attracted by order and so you
know you always have to give the devil
his due if you're trying to understand
something like Nazism you have to
understand why it might be attractive to
someone like you now the question is in
part why did it go so pathologically
wrong well that's part of what we're
going to untangle you know because you
might say well you might have benevolent
motives in establishing order but order
shades into tyranny and then your your
your motivations for establishing
tyranny might be completely self-serving
and cruel you know there may be a
process that gets you too self-serving
and cruel certainly is what happened
with the Nazis the question is was that
there all along was it something that
emerged was it like the snake in the
garden that was gonna present itself
well and you have Hitler on on the right
there and that's a Nazi art statue
behind it and you know it's kind of got
this quasi Greek element although and
and Hitler was an admirer of classical
statuary but then everything's
exaggerated about it there's this sort
of hyper-masculine well it's like hyper
masculine eyes Greek sculpture that was
the part of the Nazi aesthetic
so that one on the Left says one folk
one country one leaders that's what
furor means you know and so there you
see that Hitler's head is assimilated to
the idea of a country right so it says
this is there's something about this
country that's Hitler's head so like you
might think do you ever use symbols like
that and the answer is well as sure
every time you give someone a coin right
so Hitler's head is like the head of the
realm and so what does that mean in some
sense it means that the realm is an
embodiment of Hitler or it's an
embodiment of the leader and actually a
realm is the embodiment of the leader
because it's a body of laws and so what
it represents is a mode of being and so
that's what that expresses and then you
have him on the left there and you know
you can kind of see what sort of
emotions he thought were morally
appropriate and so it's almost a
caricature except there's a but there's
an element of seriousness about it
that's that that stops it from being a
caricature and so what do you have to
say about that picture on the right what
does that say to you yeah
yeah so those are all positive things so
far or they could be argued to be that
do you see anything that isn't like that
there's some disdain yeah that's right
who said that yeah it says I agree
there's some disdain it's partly the
narrowed eyebrows it's partly the fact
that his face is up a little bit and
disdain is associated with contempt and
disgust yeah and so I would also say
there's some arrogance in that partly
it's the sideways pose you know because
it's a real pose and so
well I think one of the things that I
think you can see in the picture is
overcompensation you know because to the
you shouldn't be any more dominant that
is necessary but you really have to be
well put together not to be more
dominant that's necessary and I think
the dominance is a compensation at least
in part for childhood inadequacy and
weakness that was actually one of the
central axioms of a blur Adlerian theory
you know that what people were doing as
they progress towards adulthood was
compensating for the inferiority of
their childhood you know and he said
they'd often overcompensate and you know
if you watch your own behavior you you
could see that happening all the time it
happens all the time it's
extraordinarily difficult not to push
any harder than you have to and
sometimes it's because you're trying to
look better than you are tougher than
you are and I think there is an element
that you can see in that because it's
like it's a bit too much you know and I
would also say one of the things I've
noticed about people who've really
mastered something is that they can do
it with a touch of humor even if it's
really serious you know and I had this
thought when I was teaching this
material probably 15 years ago I thought
there was a little voice in my head that
said well you know you should lighten up
a bit and I thought what do you mean I'm
talking about genocide it's like yeah
I'm gonna lighten up and then I thought
I was thinking about Young's notion of
the of the gesture and the Joker as a
precursor to the Savior there's this
element of subversion and humor that
goes along with attempting to crack a
difficult problem and I I thought about
that for about five years and I thought
no it's right if you if if there isn't
if there isn't something that's akin to
the sort of thing that a comedian does
when you're talking about something then
you're doing it too seriously
it means you haven't mastered it you
can't do it with a light touch so and I
think you can see that in him
well there's one on the left there
that's Hitler for president so what do
you what do you see in that yeah what
else
how how how is there an indication of
clear direction yeah absolutely it's
it's it well it's it's it's very intense
perspective so there's a force moving
upward and he's at the top of the force
of the lines go
weirdly they go to the left which is
quite interesting because generally the
way you would read a poster like that is
that harsh movement to the left is
regressive right it's backwards but you
know you can understand why that might
be and he's clearly the thing that sits
on top of the pillars remember I showed
you a picture of Osiris he may not
remember this that was Osiris his hand
on a pillar it's the same idea you know
that his body is the body of the state
and the state has this powerful movement
forward then there this is an infamous
picture this one in the middle so what
do you think about that oh yeah he's a
knight he's a white knight in fact yeah
so he's assimilated to the idea of
medieval nobility you know and in its
purest form he's a knight of the people
you know and so there's a Wagner ian
element to that and he was a great
admirer of Wagner Wagner Ian music by
the way and Hitler wanted to put music
halls in every classical music halls in
every city in Europe it was sort of
obsession of his he was obsessed with
Wagner and opera and he claimed that he
had quasi religious experiences
listening to it you know so he's a very
strange character because Hitler was
extremely appears to have been extremely
high in openness which is not something
you would expect for someone who is a
tyrant you know because conservative
people are basically very low in
openness and very high and orderliness
but he appeared to be someone who is
very high and orderliness and very high
and openness
and I think that's one of the things
that made him charismatic you know so
there's a deeply conservative element
and an element that was obsessed with
will and antithetical to chaos but he
was able to bring this tremendous
artistic force into his politicking and
it it was captivating to people
to what was compensatory yeah well I
think that's a perfectly reasonable way
of thinking about it but I also think he
was opened by temperament and so one of
the things that happens to open people
is that if they listen to music that
really captures them you know the hair
stands up on the back of their neck
they're the the experience is sort of at
hand you know and I also think it's very
easy for people to assume that if
they're having that experience that
they're being inhabited by something
that's akin to divinity you know and you
know you don't you don't want to make
light of that kind of experience because
music is incredibly gripping almost
everyone likes music you know some
people like conventional music so you
know they can tolerate a little bit of
exposure to the divine force of music
not much that's usually conservatives
because they listen to very conventional
pop music and then there's this wide
variation but almost across almost all
people music produces this influx of a
Dionysian force you know really hyper
conservatives so bad music and dancing
right so because it's subversive so and
then you have the one on the on the
right so tell me about that one
absolutely he's at the forefront of the
heroic what would you call that it's a
Roman formation yes exactly he's at the
very forefront of that you know and no
sir yes no go ahead go ahead
absolutely you know so but what's
happening if you look at that image it's
like that's Christ with the Holy Ghost
the Holy Ghost is represented by a dove
and that's often associated in Christian
symbolism with the messenger of God
you know manifesting itself and in some
sense one of the deeper deepest
Christian ideas is the idea that when
Christ died and left there was something
left behind that was still divine that
could communicate with human beings and
that was partly outside and partly
inside now the thing about Hitler is
that's not a dove that's an eagle and an
eagle is a carrion eater right it's a
bird of prey and so and it's very
interesting image because you know you
have to come to terms with the fact that
Hitler is a master of speech and that
made him a master of logos right because
that speech and communication but the
question is you know that that seemed to
be I think it's difficult to deny that
that was perverted in the favor of
something else and so the spirit that is
coming out of the Sun and flying behind
Hitler is a devouring carrion eating
bird of prey no and that's and then you
know people think Eagles they're
powerful it is that you know the
national bird of the United States
Benjamin Franklin recommended that it
would be the turkey and everyone laughs
about that but you know it's worth
thinking about
absolutely absolutely I mean there's
there's no shortage of things about
eagles that inspire admiration in people
but it's not a dove
so the message and it's black not white
you know so the message is quite you
know and the flag itself those are the
three primary colors like if you look
around cultures worldwide and you look
at names for colors every culture has a
name for black white and red and then
after that the colors fragment so that
some are more frequently named than
others you know because you can start
well yeah like it's orange red well you
know yes and no it depends on how
differentiated your your your language
is but black white and red
you know that's fruit day and night
that's one way of looking at or it's
blood day at night
so or it's rage day and night or war day
and night and so it's a powerful symbol
it's also a Sun symbol it's a Sanskrit
symbol but it's rotating backwards
instead of forwards so you know and the
Nazis were very aware in many ways of
the meanings of the images that they
were using but I'm showing you this
because I want to show you how the
archetypes were captured by the
propagandist propagandists or how the
archetypes were actually manifesting
themselves in some sense to produce the
kind of powerful grip that Hitler had
over his audience and it was certainly
the archetypes of order the archetypes
of heroism all of those are being put at
the service of a political ideology well
they're both it depends on the image you
know so in some images he's more like
the father of the people in other images
he's more like the heroic Marduk at the
at the forefront of the march into
battle with with the illuminated gods
behind them so and there's no reason for
him not to take on both symbolic aspects
like we know for example that as far as
the as the Egyptians were concerned
ideal Pharaoh was half Osiris and half
Horus right so in embodied stability and
also the vision and the capacity to
update that stability so so this is
actually counter-propaganda
or maybe it's not maybe it's an attempt
to represent the part of Hitler that
isn't being represented by the German
propaganda so on the left you have well
those are not see snakes they've got
swastikas all over them and so that's an
interesting image as far as I'm
concerned because you see how logical it
is to use the image of the knotted up
snakes and there's a frog in there too
by the way
snakes and frogs all knotted together
makes a representation of the enemy the
evil enemy like you get that at a glance
right you don't need that bloody thing
interpreted it makes perfect sense
you know and you see the same things
interestingly enough I think I showed
you some of them in representations of
Mary when she's holding the infant out
of the way of the snake or the lizard
that she's stepping on it's a very
similar idea and then you have Hitler's
head there as a spreading Hydra
you know he's sort of like a figure of
death he's he's sort of like Ursula in
the Little Mermaid
you know except he's he's well it's not
only a masculine image that because the
spreading tentacles that's snake-like
again and so there's an element of the
Medusa there so that's a very archaic
symbol you know and then you have
another image on the right there which
is you know a graphical representation
of Hitler and his head is tangled up
with a snake so you can see the reason
those images have power is because
they're they're taking the power that's
implicit in the archetype and harnessing
it for a message that's intent in a
sense actually what propaganda is like
if you know the nature of the message
that you're using the archetype to
promote then it's propaganda if you're
trying to figure something else out and
the symbolic representations come to
mind as part of the creative process
then that's not propaganda but then it
also usually means that you end up
producing a piece of art that you
actually don't understand you know and
there's still lots of Renaissance
artists like that like it contains
information that we haven't even come
close to processing yet you know and I
think most artistic representations are
you know partly propaganda and promptly
are partly art it depends on the
representation so then on the left you
have again that's that's anti-nazi
that's an anti-nazi poster and you have
the idea of the dark figure lurking in
the background who's sort of everywhere
gazing at you so that's like George
Orwell's big brother right so that's
definitely harnessing the idea of the
terrible aspect of the Great Father and
I really like this one on the on the
right because that's basically well
that's the Virgin and Child you know
it's not it's not precisely a Christian
image it doesn't matter because that's
not precisely a Christian representation
but she's beautiful and young and she's
holding something that's very vulnerable
in her arms and then you see these hands
at the top they're not see and at the
bottom they're Japanese because the
symbols are on them and so ones coming
from one end and ones coming from the
other and so what are the hands look
like hmm well yeah but why what's hot
what makes them evil yeah they have
claws so they're predatory right and
they're wizened so they're sort of like
death and they're black you know the
thing is it's so obvious right you know
those are evil hands the question is why
do you know that they're evil hands you
know what is it about the image that
announces itself in that way it's also
partly because of their juxtaposition
with the image of purity so that's
really the absolute corrupt Great Father
reaching out for the absolute perfect
feminine and hero the baby hero and
threatening that
so there's semantic Jewish propaganda on
the right there so first of all the
Jewish guy is represented as a money
changer and he's associated with the the
Soviet Union because they they Nazis
drew a tight relationship between Jews
and communism and so that was
amalgamated into the same kind of threat
and then and certainly the case that
Germany was threatened by communism I
mean there's absolutely no doubt about
that but they sort of loved their
enemies into one category and so what do
you think about the representation on
the right what does it say I don't
believe so a whole did you say yeah no I
don't I don't think so so his eyes are
closed that's kind of interesting
his hands is outstretched with money and
he seems to be I would say his hand head
is oriented towards the money yes is
that is that right so I don't know what
he's leaning on exactly I don't know
what that is but it's obviously not a
flattering representation and then you
have the middle representation yes
yeah that's a good one yeah yeah there
is a goal of element to that do you want
to explain what that means
yeah it's like a zombie
right so yes so so there's that there's
a sort of undead element to the
representation blind focused only on
money you know and then also aligned
with this terrible destructive force of
communism so another comment yes right
right yeah good point good point yes so
then there's the middle one then you see
the juxtaposition of the Jewish Star of
David with the Communist hammer and
sickle and you see the whole world on
fire and death emerging from that right
so there's a there's an idea of the
ultimate a car apocalypse behind that
there's an idea of hell behind that
there's an idea of like the Living Dead
and and then you know and this is
something that's sitting on top of the
worlds it's very satanic image I think
it says I don't know it's Bolshevik part
of that is and I don't know if there's
an amalgam there is if isthmus is a
reference to Jewishness or not I think
it says Bolshevism unmasked it's
something like that so you know and the
idea that that the Nazis were
anti-communist was a very powerful idea
for people it made the morality of the
situation very murky in many ways
because for example when the Nazis went
into Russia through the Ukraine the
Ukrainian started to fight with the
Nazis like alongside of them to get rid
of the Communists because as far as they
were concerned the Communists were worse
than the Nazis so you know it was a race
to the bottom that's for sure and then
it's so interesting because you see the
fire the destructive fire in the middle
and then on the Left well those are
crematoriums I believe they're from
Auschwitz and that those are the
remnants of the destroyed bodies in the
ovens so you know all of that death and
destruction was being projected in some
sense all the evil was being projected
onto the Communists and the Jews and you
know that allowed the exactly the same
to manifest itself in in actuality in
Germany we show that's the laying out of
the bodies on the left and then that's
Hitler closer to the end of the war and
you know he's looking pretty Haggard and
his mouth is down and his countenance
has fallen which is a phrase that will
encounter next week so you know you see
this image of Hitler on the left he sort
of friend to children with the mother
looking on happily in the back and
everybody's smiling and happy and then
in the middle you see someone who's been
burned one of the things that happened
when the Nazis marched the Jews out of
the camps when the Allies were coming is
now and then they put a bunch of people
in a barn and light it on fire and I
believe that that's an image from that
and then that's a prisoner at the bottom
from one of the who didn't die from one
of the Holocaust camps so I would say
you know the problem with the image on
the left is that it doesn't factor in
the image on in the middle and that's
the thing about propaganda you know it's
like it's all good it's like ya know and
if it's presenting itself is all good
then you got to ask yourself well
where's the snake because there's always
a snake and I would say the more
something represents itself as pure good
the bigger the snake so you know
Dostoyevsky knew that when he started
writing anti utopian anti utopian ideas
especially notes from underground he'd
already figured out that if someone was
promising you heaven that the
probability that there was a hell
lurking in there somewhere was well it
was a hundred percent so and part of the
reason that I've been working on the
ideas in this book and presenting them
to people for so long as I'm trying to
inoculate people against the temptations
of utopian thinking and propaganda
because you should always be asking
yourself where is the other half if
nature is all beautiful well what about
the destructive part you know and if
you're offering a utopia well aren't you
also a devil and a tyrant like what are
you going to do with that part
yeah what what you're gonna do is you're
gonna say well I'm not the devil and the
tyrant it's those people over there it's
like which only proves that you are in
fact both the devil and the tyrant but
it's much easier for people to put that
out somewhere else you know because do
you really want to deal with it you know
you said at the beginning of the class
he wrote out what horrible things might
happen to you if you didn't behave
properly and that's unsettling because
you have to recognize in yourself the
capacity to bring something like that
about it's even worse than that because
people can bring that sort of thing
about and really enjoy it well it's
happening you know in a really corrupt
and destructive way it's a revenge
they're looking for revenge and if they
have to take it on themselves that's no
problem it just makes the revenge even
sweeter
so there's juxtapositions again you know
so I've got the crowd that's surrounding
Hitler all happy at the dinner table
there on the left and then you know
that's cart loads of bodies that were
taken away from the concentration camps
when the Allies came in so there's the
tyrannical father and the and the
positive father you know
and that I believe is from Nuremberg
although I'm not absolutely certain
about so Nuremberg was the place where
the massive Nazi spectacles were held
you know you can see the Greek and Roman
symbolism there like the classical idea
that there was a reestablishment of a
enlightened classical society brilliant
use of light against dark which
something was something that the Nazi as
theit's were unbelievably good at the
use of fire and light and black white
and red contrast very very powerful
imagery I would say literature does
great literature does because it
presents people as the battleground
between chaos and order and good and
evil every person so you know someone
might be tilted towards the good in a
great piece of literature but they're
not they're not comic-book superhero you
know and I mean even the comic books
when they were DC comic books it was
pretty damn clear Superman he was all
good the evils evil villains they were
all villainous when the Marvel what
would you call mythologist sort of
emerged in the 1960s all the characters
became more nuanced and you know they're
more palatable to I would say a martyred
mind but also of course older people are
paying attention to the comic-book
characters now they're not before they
were for like ten year olds you know so
they like they couldn't handle the
complexity of something that was more
than one thing at the same time but but
like if you look at great literature the
heroes are often 51% good and 49% evil
you know and there's a
battle going on inside them and outside
of them and so that makes it a lot more
nuanced and complex but it's also in
some ways much more frustrating to read
so yeah so I would say the greater the
literature and the more it approximates
aren't the more balanced the portrayal
of the entire scenario so you have the
chaos in the background you have the
positive and negative feminine in
various manners you have the tyrant and
the secure father you have the adversary
in the hero they have the whole picture
is painted you see the same thing I
think in in any great art so that's what
makes it great yes exactly it tilts into
either oversimplification or propaganda
so and it's dangerous especially
especially when it harnesses the
archetypal forces so one of the things
that's happened since Nietzsche
announced the death of God is that
political entities have appropriated the
archetypes we think well the gods are
still in those archetypes there's no
getting rid of them so the question is
who's going to be using them and for
what you know because we think well
we've transcended all that it's like
yeah right you know you go see the
Avengers you know so you haven't
transcended it at all in fact you're
more boneheaded about it then people
were 200 years ago because now it's
comic-book superheroes instead of
transcendent deities I don't see that as
a consumption a conceptual improvement I
see it as a regression so and that's a
general who shot himself to death
a Nazi general you know when the victory
of the Allies was certain and Hitler by
that time basically the way Hitler
rationalized his defeat was the Germans
let me down Berlin should burn and if
the Russians come in and rape and
pillage the people who had happens to
deserve it so that was his final
judgement on the German people it wasn't
that there was something wrong with him
is that it was that they just failed him
and so they weren't up to the glorious
task that he had set them and
they deserved all the rack and room that
was being visited on them so and when I
look at that and I see what happened
Hitler shot himself in a bunker far
below but Berlin when Europe was on fire
I think what makes you think that wasn't
what he was after from the beginning no
one thinks that they think oh well you
know he wanted to build an empire
dominate the world and all those things
it's like why would you think that
there's an old psychoanalytic idea if
you don't understand the motivation look
at the consequences and infer the
motivation it's extraordinarily
intelligent idea so you can't figure out
what someone's up to okay what happens
when they do whatever they're doing well
if it's utter catastrophe and pain and
ruin you might think oh well there was
some part of him that was aiming at that
now you know you have to factor out the
effects of random chance but there was
nothing random about what Hitler did to
Europe quite the contrary
you know and you might ask yourself why
did he open up a two-front war you know
he wasn't historically ignorant he kind
of knew by that point that attacking
Russia was probably not the best thing
to do if he actually wanted to win the
war now you know you could say that he
was arrogant and overvalued the the
power of the of the Nazi war machine and
was too contemptuous of the Russians and
part of him no doubt felt that way but
by the same token you can't suppress the
suspicion that the darkest parts of them
thought that's the fastest way to Iraq
and rude
he certainly produced it so I assume
that the person is aiming for what they
say they're aiming for especially if
they use means that are as undeniably
evil as anything you could possibly come
across top left that Stalin and so
there's an old guy kissing a statue of
Stella and a gold statue still and
that's after the wall fell you know in
Stellan was an utter monster you know he
made Hitler into he made Hitler up in
many ways Hitler was a compared to
Stalin and one of the very funny
about Hitler that's extraordinarily
funny in the worst possible manner is
that one of the only people he ever
trusted
sorry Stalin one of the people only
people that Stella never trusted was
Hitler so he prepared he failed to
prepare the Russian army the Soviet Army
for a potential invasion by the Germans
because Hitler said he wouldn't invade
and so when the Germans finally showed
up they just blew the Russians back
they were completely unprepared you know
and if the Russians couldn't have had
the Germans freeze to death because of
the winter there's little doubt that the
Germans would have overrun the Soviet
Union I mean the Russians were tough and
they fought like mad but they were
completely and utterly unprepared so
okay okay so what we've been doing now
like we're I'm kind of working towards
the idea we're moving up the food chain
in some sense so we talked about chaos
and we talked about the Great Mother and
now we've talked about the Great Father
and we're sort of tilting up towards the
final level of analysis which is the
relationship between the individual and
the adversary and then the relationship
between both of those and the other
levels you know and we touched on that a
little bit today because we could see
how Hitler was presented both as Great
Father but also as you know heroic
leader into the future you see the same
thing with Stalin there where he's shown
as you know leader of the ship of state
and he's far as I'm concerned he's
nothing different than Captain Hook
who's a tyrant because he's afraid that
he's afraid of his own mortality he's
afraid of the fact that the crocodile
has already got a piece of him that
turns him into a tyrant he's terrified
of chaos terrified of the positive
feminine for that matter
and there you know what you see well
there's Stalin you know the father of
all Soviet people loving music friend to
women and children you know and there's
a statue of Stalin that was toppled
after the Berlin Wall fell and it's
covered with red paint well you can
imagine what that indicates I really
like the one on the left
that's Stella I mean I look at that only
think you could hardly
if you were attempting to build a
representation of the devil himself
enveloped in flames you could hardly do
a better job than that picture you know
I'm it's it's and then on the law on the
left on the right there you have Lenin
in the background and Stalin in the
foreground on the flag you know so those
are the the two deities of the Russian
state they're what replaced God once you
know once Nietzsche had announced God
was dead it was like okay well what's
gonna come up and fill that void it's
like oh good it's Hitler and Lenin and
Stalin that's a real improvement that's
Mao on the left there and you know the
estimates are that he was involved in
the death of about a hundred million
people so which you never hear anything
about he was also a hero of the radical
left in the 1960s anyways we'll stop for
now